oh my
have you done something different with
your peepers
like maybe swap them out for a pair of
freakishly oversized fly eyes how would
you see the world around you
what would you look like to other people
and
how would this change your buzz life
i mean love life
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you had eyes like a fly
it's an understatement to say a fly's
eyes are a little different from yours
these insects have to compound eyes
that's like having a bunch of little
eyes that allow them to see movement
from many different directions
your human eyes are structured more like
a camera
there's an iris that controls the amount
of light each eye lets in
a lens that forms the image and a retina
that then detects that image
compare that to the compound eyes of a
fly
which are made up of 4 500 lenses each
you might think that that would give
them incredible optical abilities but
each eye doesn't actually see all that
well
but combine them and they form an almost
360 degree field of vision
[Music]
so
if you had fly eyes
would you instantly possess superhuman
sight
your eyes might be the window to your
soul but when your loved ones look at
you now
they'd certainly be peering through a
very
very different window
now before you attempt to fly away in
this scenario you'd only be doing an eye
swap
the rest of your body would stay exactly
the same
but what you'd see
would be completely different
you'd now have a nearly 360 degree
picture of all that's going on around
you
no more worrying about people sneaking
up on you
this built-in security system comes at a
price
everything would be blurry
you wouldn't have pupils so say goodbye
to controlling the amount of light
coming through the lenses to help keep
things in focus
also you'd no longer be able to see
colors like you're used to
your old human eyes were marvelously
advanced in this regard
but now you wouldn't be able to see all
the different shadings cues and levels
of vividness anymore
flies only have two sensor cells which
gives them trouble distinguishing
between colors
with your new fly eyes the color red
would be out of the picture
literally
i hope it wasn't your favorite
there are some insects with compound
eyes that see color better
bees for one
they even see colors better than we do
makes sense when you consider that
distinguishing different flowers is
vital to their survival
but back to flies if you found yourself
with a pair of eyes from a male fly
you'd also now have the so-called love
spot
this would enhance your ability to
process visual signals by up to 60
percent
this enables male flies to better detect
the fast movements of their female
counterparts
well you'd look pretty crazy darting
your head around all day looking for a
date
then again you'd be a human with
colossal compound eyes so
you'd already look a little bonkers as
it is
and bonkers would be an appropriate
description of the physical appearance
of these eyes
which would also have intense patterns
adding to the mystique
researchers aren't exactly sure why
some think mating plays a big role
well who knows
maybe you'd start suddenly attracting
hundreds of flies of the opposite sex
all that buzzing would be worse than
being text bomb
probably better to keep your human eyes
after all
instead you could try out a camera
scientists have built to detect movement
just like a fly does
the problem is the photos would be black
and white
i'm pretty sure your cell phone could do
better
now maybe you'd prefer a different kind
of vision
x-ray vision
well
that's a story for another
what if
[Music]